[Music]
so the first question that comes to mind
after watching the final episode of
Monarch the legacy of monsters is why
did Godzilla and the iron dragon fight
how big was the iron dragon and how
powerful was it compared to the other
Titans scen in the previous movies well
these are the Titan questions that are
floating around in the internet right
now along with what in the world is that
place you know the place they were in a
topic for another video here we will
discuss in detail all about the Titan
fight in the final episode let's get to
it so firstly let's discuss what are the
events that led to the climactic battle
between these two deadly looking
reptilian Titans so in the previous
episode number eight Lee Shaw May and
Kate Randa while they were in Kazakhstan
fell into one of the holes that Koo was
dragged into by the those insectoid
endos swarmers back in 1959 they fell
into some sort of Vortex that
transported them into an underspace A
world beneath the surface where strange
creatures weird plants and unexplained
energy phenomena is common it is unsure
as to what this place really was but it
was home to the Titans seen in the
series home to the Bramble boore the
endos swarmers the frost bar and the
Iron Dragon in the final episode they
reunited with Geo Randa who was lost in
1959 but was seemingly still the same
age even after 56 years had passed this
was explained in the show that the place
they were in existed in a different time
space continuum a different Dynamics
from this world due to the strange
gravitational effects and inversion that
also made the vortexes possible to occur
anyway they then hatched a plan to use
an old Monarch capsule from The
Hourglass mission that leak came in in
1962 to return to the surface but in
order to do so they would have to
trigger a guy hamar Ray machine the
lears tightens into their location
effectively being the only way to open a
sort of a wormhole this didn't go
according to plan though as the Iron
Dragon was already there in that under
space in the axis Mundi as Geo calls it
but just before they became dragon food
Godzilla entered the space through the
vortex passageway like a scene from
Avengers endgame he came in and
immediately saw the humans trying to
escape but then Godzilla was attacked by
the Iron Dragon and now let's dis
discuss this fight in
detail so the Iron Dragon when it was
seen firstly in the Philippines in 1952
wasn't as large as we thought it would
be it looked to be around 30 to 40 ft or
around 9 to 12 m in height and having a
wingspan of over 200 ft or 60 M well
roughly but here in the axis mundai the
under space it was huge Titan size
around the same as the male Muto of
2014 although shorter in height of
course due to the muto's longer insect
to legs but nevertheless having a
wingspan of over 500 ft or 150 M wide
this was clear when Godzilla was in the
end of the fight holding the one of the
wings of the Iron Dragon and that single
wing seems to be more than half the
height of the Gman so given that Goji is
almost 400 ft tall that would put the
single wing around 250 ft and so by
simple mathematics that means 500 ft
Wing to Wing plus the body width as well
so 500 plus feet the fight was short and
sweet it began with the Iron Dragon
attacking Godzilla as he was entering
the Dark Realm Godzilla here was still
attracted to the GMA Ray device which
was turned on learing him in but
unbeknownst to the king of the monsters
the Iron Dragon had silently taken
notice of the Big G entering his domain
and since it was highly territorial of
its space it flew around and pounced on
Godzilla from the back biting hard on
the king's neck but even with its spiky
sharp teeth it did not have the bite
force necessary to sustain any damage
nor the strength to sustain the attack
even though this was a surprise attack
Godzilla with his immense experience in
battle bit off a bit of the tail of the
Iron Dragon and retaliated immediately
and threw the smaller Titan to a nearby
Mountain but this black beast was
persistent and flew around for another
round of attack bouncing on Godzilla
with its claws its tager tail and
spraying Godzilla with a sticky Necker
secretion which for a moment distracted
the Big G but even with the consistent
claw attacks and bite attempts Godzilla
wiped his face and got a hold of the
iron dragon's leg and just as with the
muto male the only thing that extended
the battle for so long was the
nimbleness of the flying Titan and
Godzilla's inability to get a hold of it
so as soon as he grabbed the leg the
fight was done Godzilla fight has
already charged Atomic breath at the
Iron Dragon and stunned the Titan for a
while but it wasn't dead though showing
a high resilience to the heat ray so the
Big G grabbed both of its wings and tore
the dragon apart with his powerful hands
and all the while the dragon still
trying to fight back but this was the
end and the tatted body was thrown into
the radiation screen and created a
Vortex for the humans to escape to the
surface now why did these two Titans
fight shouldn't the Iron Dragon already
know that Godzilla was an alpha and it
by itself wasn't well aside from the
series being Beyond logic as per the
episode's name the only reason they
fought was because of the humans trying
to escape not that the Titans were good
or evil but it was due to the GMA raay
divice Godzilla entered there thinking
it was a source of GMA radiation energy
source or maybe it was another Titan
calling it so was the case for the Iron
Dragon but even though godzill was the
alpha there he was mainly in the surface
world where his King status was known
where it was said to be his domain and
the other space is by all intents and
purposes the Realm of the Iron Dragon so
this battle was purely defensive
territorially for the Iron Dragon and
also a surprise for Godzilla
nevertheless the King won the fight and
the dragon lost it with its life now as
for the iron dragon's power on the Titan
scale meaning compared to the others
that have been seen in the prior movies
it rangs somewhere in the middle low
rankings it is no doubt stronger than
the skull devil of Skull Island and the
one seen in GVK maybe even stronger than
the male Muto certain aspects and weaker
in others it is nowhere close to being
at the top tier list though even though
it has its own dark domain so the Titans
like Rodan Mothra kot and Gora would no
doubt defeat it while titanis Doug the
male Muto and the skull crawlers would
be lesser than it its verocity would be
its strong point while its relatively
smallest size would be its main down
point now we have come to the end of
this video If you like this then watch
this other one as well and do check out
our channel for other monster content
like subscribe and we'll see you in the
next video take care fam